[Music]
this idea of there being multiple
universes
in in space as this was a way in which
you can explain the fine tunings
there's a large gap at the moment
between the empirical evidence and the
theory
so the idea is that every time a black
hole forms you're actually producing a
new universe on the other side
of the black hole
[Music]
the multiverse is a really
interesting extension of
um what we call inflation theory um
so right after the big bang um
the majority of um theories about how
our universe was formed requires a very
rapid period of inflation
in the very very early universe um and
there are many many different models for
how this very rapid period of inflation
could have occurred
but the majority of these models are
called chaotic inflation theory models
and they predict that not just one
universe would be created
that multiple universes would be created
and this lends itself to the idea of
there being
a multiverse um you can kind of i like
to imagine
um blowing bubbles they're just being
lots of bubbles of different shapes and
different sizes around that's kind of
your
this this idea of there being multiple
universes
in in space um
when i first started thinking about the
multiverse i really didn't like it
because i thought
uh this isn't a theory i can test
because i
i physically can't see anything outside
my own observable universe
um and i think i said at the start
there's no point in coming up with a
theory if you can't test it
and but actually we can test these
theories of inflation
so if we can we can test theories
and if they make a prediction that a
multiverse is the consequence of that
theory then that's a great way of
actually testing this idea of there
being multiple universes out there
so we can test these inflation theories
um in the very early universe when the
universe experienced this period of
rapid inflation that would imprint
gravitational waves so it's an
incredibly um
powerful event that you should still be
able to see the ripples of
now in uh in gravitational waves now
there's been the first detection of
gravitational waves recently
this is not my area of work it's
absolutely phenomenal what these
scientists have managed to do
and so it's just giving them time now to
improve their
instrumentation their technology so we
can get down to the sort of levels where
we'll be able to see
the remnants of this rapid period of
inflation and then you can really test
these models
are these chaotic inflation models the
way to go
does that really infer that there are
multiple universes out there
my final reasoning for why the
multiverse is a very um
very useful theory is the fact that you
exist
that we all exist and so i've talked
about these uh
four fundamental forces in our universe
these govern everything
around us but they are surprisingly well
tuned um for life so there are loads of
different examples here but i'll just
take you through a couple of them
um so the electromagnetic force that's
what keeps electrons and protons
together
if you changed the constant that decided
how well they stuck together
if you changed it by just four percent
so that's a really tiny amount
the sun would explode no sun no life
they're just four percent that's that's
not we haven't got much room for wiggle
room there
uh what about the weak strong nuclear
force and the and the weak nuclear force
if you change that just by
two percent um the hydrogen
would only last for about two minutes
after the big bang before it got turned
into helium and all sorts of other
things
if you don't have lots of hydrogen
created in the big bang you don't create
stars if you don't create stars you
don't create life
so again just change that number by just
two percent
uh if you increase the amount of
electron i think by only a few percent
dna cannot form if you decrease the mass
of the electron
no stars can form this is one of the
smallest ones if you increase the mass
of a proton by just
point two percent just point two percent
atoms cannot form
so this is known um as a fine
tuning problem in physics and and
scientists we don't like
fine-tuning problems we don't like the
fact that that we don't understand how
constants are
and so the fact that we're here
suggests we're in a very special
universe a very special universe where
everything seems to be just right
for stars and planets and life to form
and that would make sense if there were
multiple universes
out there with lots of different
realizations of physics naturally we
would be
in the one that was perfectly tuned for
life
but i'm sure a lot of you are more
interested in
the kind of the extension of of that
idea the other world
theory so i've talked about there being
other universes out there uh that those
other universities probably are not well
tuned to life that we happen to be in
a really nice universe um but there is
an extension to this idea of the
multiverse and that's the idea of the
other world so i'm sure you all know the
idea of schrodinger's cat
it's in a box is it alive is it dead
uh and the idea of quantum physics is
there's no black and white there's no
right or wrong
there's a whole range of different
probabilities of different outcomes
and all of these different realities are
possible
uh it's just as likely that the cat is
alive as
dead and but the action of looking
defines which reality
uh that you are in now the extension of
this multiverse idea to this other world
theory is that every time we make an
action
that uh that defines the reality that
we're in but the other action could just
as likely happen
and that the universe splits in that
sense
so for all of the gentlemen without
beards here this evening
maybe that was a decision you took but
maybe in another reality you have very
fine goatees
who knows um but it's it's an
interesting
um extension of this idea of the
multiverse theory
it's again another thing that scientists
get really anxious about
um and we have you know is is this just
going too far is this mathematics uh
really pushing us into some
fantasy that it's no real guide of
reality and
and to that i'd say the same sort of
answer that i've been talking about with
multiverse
no we cannot test this this theory
directly
we cannot test if every time we make a
decision uh you've made an alternative
decision somewhere else no we can't test
that directly
but we can test quantum theory and
quantum theory suggests
that this should naturally happen and
maybe there's a nice connection between
these ideas of the multiverse
and these other world scenarios
now the point about the multiverse
you i should make clear right at the
outset is the word multiverse is used in
many different ways
they're different types of multiverse
and you need to distinguish between
these before you actually start
making dogmatic statements about it the
simplest type of
multiverse is what techmark was level
one is simply the multiverse which says
that
beyond the universe we can observe the
universe began with a big bang
14 billion years ago we can't see
further than 14 billion light years
roughly
but there must be a universe that exists
beyond that so
it's simply saying there are patches of
the universe which we can't observe
and you might choose to call those other
universes i think that's pretty
indisputable
but the more controversial claim
is that there are also different
universes which are not actually
spatially connected to our universe and
the basic idea is that if you have any
any theory for the big bang because
ultimately physicists want to explain
where the big bang came from
well if you have a model which produces
one big bang obviously in principle it
can produce other big bangs
and so cosmologists and particle
physicists have come
up with all sorts of ways in which they
can produce many universes you can have
cyclic universes you can have um
i won't even go through them all because
it would take too long to go through
them all
but it's important to say that some of
these suggestions come from cosmologists
and some come from particle physicists
because particle physics is also in
their own way have produced
other ideas of the multiverse now the
third type of multiverse is that is the
parallel worlds of
of everett the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
and again i won't get into that maybe
cara will say more about that
but that's a third way and the the
fourth version of the multiverse
is even more controversial which comes
from max taymark who says that
basically anything which can exist
mathematic
exists mathematically must exist
somewhere
now that's very controversial i don't
personally uh
find that idea attractive so they're
these four different
levels of the multiverse the first i
would say is pretty well inevitable
the second is really what's interesting
and the third one is to do with quantum
theory which is
no one understands quantum theory anyway
and the fourth says fantasy so so then
let's really focus on the question of
whether there are other universes of
type 2
other big bangs the first point to say
is that physicists have independently
come
up with theories for the multiverse
that's to say
cosmologists on the one hand and
particle physicists on the other
you've heard a lot about m theory and
one of the predictions of m theory is
that there could be lots of vacuum
states called the string landscape and
things like that
so so that is one reason for taking it
seriously but i also have to say that
one of the reasons the multiverse became
so popular was because
it was realized this was a way in which
you can explain the fine tunings
because if you have all these different
universes with all these different
values of the constants
then it simply becomes a selection
effect that we have to be in one of the
universes
which is conducive for life so in some
sense the multiverse
does provide a possible explanation for
this mystery which was already existing
i'm saying that because i don't want to
give the impression that people only
thought up the multiverse in order to
explain
the fine tunings there were independent
reasons to believing in the multiverse
and and that's why many of us at least
like to connect these
two ideas but i've spoken rather long so
maybe i should let someone else carry on
at this i just like to ask a follow-up
question because some people
some people not necessarily me some
people claim that multiverses
might be a convenient way of getting
around the question
of fine tuning simply because you could
have any possible
combination do you have any arguments to
combat that
yes i mean there are many
criticisms of the multiverse or i should
say many criticizes
of the of the multiverse and that the
main criticism
is simply that we have no observational
evidence
for these other universes so it's fine
as a speculation
but but there's actually no evidence for
them because we by definition we can't
see something which is being on the
horizon
and therefore people say this is doomed
forever to be mere
philosophy sorry not mere philosophy
doomed to be
philosophy thank you and uh that doesn't
mean it's wrong it just means it
wouldn't be part of
normal science and i can only say that
of course this this argument has a lot
of weight
but i can only say that i harbor the
hope
that there are ways eventually of
getting evidence for the multiverse and
maybe we'll come on to that in the third
part of the session um until that is the
case i i take the view that these ideas
exist in a sort of
a gray area between what i call
cosmology and metacosmology it's not
proper science but it's it's in a state
of purgatory where
it hasn't yet been promoted by evidence
because until you have actual evidence
for it
it isn't proper science so i agree with
the criticisms but nevertheless
this i would take the view that any
explanation is better than none
even if it's not going to be classified
as science and and that's why i'm i'm
keen on the idea
[Music]
the multiverse is the idea that it might
be that our universe isn't the only one
that there might be
more universes beyond our own beyond the
boundaries of our own
uh and some people are even saying there
might be an infinite number of universes
beyond our own
and why is this seen as sort of a
problem or that
spans religion and science yeah
so the reason is that the multiverse
idea has been around for a long time i
mean
in western philosophy it actually has
about a 2500 year history
but it's come really resurging back in
the last couple of decades
um partly because physicists are looking
for
an answer to why the universe seems so
finely tuned
why it seems like all of the constants
of nature are precisely
set so that the universe can can emerge
can sustain life things like that um and
the danger for physics
is that if you say that the universe
seems really well
tuned for life that the theologians can
rush in and say ah god did that fine
tuning right god is a kind of cosmic mix
maker who's like
setting this amount of gravity and this
amount of dark energy and this amount of
electrons right um and so a rival
explanation to god is no no no actually
there are an infinite number of
universes that take on
all sorts of different configurations
over infinite time every once in a while
one comes along that happens to work and
we seem to be in one of those universes
that works
okay yeah could that argument still work
with a god though
absolutely this is the thing about
theology right it's remarkably uh
resilient
right a theologian can always say right
fine there's a multiverse good god
created the multiverse
and then the multiverse created the
universe so it's not actually
any kind of argument the multiverse
isn't any argument against the existence
of god sometimes physicists think it is
it's not um it just sort of takes some
of its jobs away but it's not it doesn't
disprove anything
so i actually think that it's kind of
uninteresting
to be stuck in this back and forth over
whether or not god exists right with
respect to the multiverse i think the
more interesting question is
um what kinds of new stories are we
getting from these multiverse
cosmologies like new stories about
where we come from where we're headed
what the universe is like um these are
all questions that myths
used to ask and answer for us uh in in
any society other than our own right now
this would be the function of myths
physics is doing it for us now so i like
to
look at those stories and see what kinds
of values they're encoding
uh what they're telling us about
ourselves whether we like them or not
right are they are they telling us good
helpful things um
yeah so what are some of these news
stories that they're telling us
right so i mean there are tons of them
if you ask
you know most theoretical physicists
they'll say right well there's only one
respectable one
the respectable one is that there's this
sort of primordial
sea of inflationary energy inflationary
energy
pushes space out really really super
fast um
and this primordial sea uh races and
races and races outward
and every once in a while that energy
kind of turns off
and allows little pockets of stable
space time to form and those are
universes so you get these universes
nucleating out of this sort of
primordial see like sort of pockets of
um air in swiss cheese or something like
that so universal universe universe
universe this is called eternal
inflation
and the idea is that our universe is one
of just these bubbles in this
eternal sea of inflating sort of hyper
space time that's one of them
there are other theories that argue that
every time a
massive massive star collapses and forms
a black hole
you get so that you've probably seen
drawings right space time kind of going
like this
you get an infinite amount of stuff
in uh in zeros but you have stuff
crammed into no space so you've got a
sort of point of infinite density
that point is called the singularity
physicists also talk about singularities
as or thus singularity as having been uh
what the big bang was
right a bunch of stuff crammed into a
point of no size
so the idea is that every time a black
hole forms you're actually producing a
new universe on the other side
of the black hole so we may have right
hundreds of
millions of black holes in our sort of
visible universe and each of them the
idea is would have
potentially a universe inside it and
conversely we're sitting
on the inside of somebody else's black
hole right in that universe that's
another idea
uh an idea that people love to ridicule
is the idea that
our universe is all sitting on a three
plus one dimensional
membrane and that that membrane has like
a partner universe which is also a three
plus one dimension three plus one three
of space one of time
and they're sort of hovering near each
other separated
by this fourth dimension of space that
nobody can see but it's like right there
so this other universe would be like
right here just
closer than anything to us but we just
can't cross
the gap to that other universe that
every like couple trillion years or so
these two membranes smash together
that's the big bang the universe is
destroyed recreated all the time and
and we've got this kind of symbol
crashing that
uh makes and unmakes the universe these
are some ideas right
i find this fascinating right why not
look at these new stories and and ask
what it is they're telling us
[Music]
but that to me gets to the question uh
the difference between
something that is compatible with a
mathematical description
or a mathematical theory compatible with
a logical
description or logical theory and
something that actually is in fact the
case
right so uh when i hear
things like for instance string theory
predicts
a certain number you know a different
number of universes well
not really right what it does is it's
compatible its mathematics
is compatible with the existence of a
large number of differently arranged
universes
that's not the same as making a
prediction in order to make a prediction
yet to somehow
some somehow bridge the gap between the
mathematical
theory and empirical evidence and that's
what that's where you uh you know your
discomfort should we say with the
multiverse i think is justified right
because there is the question you know
the the
the fundamental issue in science is
everything stops at the back of the
empirical evidence
if there is no empirical evidence it's
not science end of story
even though a lot of well not a lot a
good number of physicists this day are
beginning to talk about
something that worries me particularly
which is called post-empirical science
okay post-empirical science is uh
something that to me sounds a lot like
metaphysics and i don't have a problem
with metaphysics but the physicists
usually do have a problem with the
physics
right so what i think might be helpful
here
uh and you were actually going in that
direction already quite a bit
is to make a distinction not there are
no sharp distinctions between physics
and metaphysics i think
or between physics uh you know science
and philosophy necessarily
but there are distinctions that i think
need to be made
and one of the problems why i think so
many philosophers and so many physicists
are uncomfortable with both string
theory and the multiverse
is precisely because especially when it
comes down to books published for the
general public
that distinction is completely blurred
if you read the elegant universe by
brian greene
i did and when i read it i got the
impression that oh this is this is
physics this is you know the physicists
have in fact
basically settled this issue or close to
settle this issue
nowhere near and the reason no it's
nowhere near it is precisely because
there is a large gap at the moment
between the empirical evidence and the
theory
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
you